ça
[Musique]
samsung a dévoilé par erreur son
smartphone pliable dans une vidéo
publiée sur internet
la bourde vient de samsung vietnam qui a
publié une vidéo avant de la retirer
rapidement mais bien évidemment vous
pensez bien que derrière il ya plein de
monde pour le récupérer très rapidement
la rediffuser la republier si bien qu'on
peut se demander est ce qu'au final
c'est pas fait exprès de la métro ligne
justement montrer rapidement ce
smartphone à écran pliable
on sait jamais si au final ces fuites
ces rumeurs sont parle peu orchestrée
par les marques
toujours est il que ça fait une autre
affaire ça fait notre bonheur il s'agit
d'une vidéo qui pourrait diffuser à
l'impact du 20 février prochain lors de
la présentation des futurs samsung
galaxy s 10 on voit dans cette vidéo
plusieurs produits de samsung des
innovations un robot qui va faire un
tatouage un smartphone avec un petit
accessoire qui permet de faire une
échographie enfin on va mal de choses ça
c'est intéressant et on voit par deux
fois
ce smartphone à écran pliable pour l
extrait avec le smartphone à écran
pliable
il arrive une fois et voilà le deuxième
extrait pourquoi est ce que cette fuite
est intéressante c'est tout simplement
parce que les smartphones à écran
pliable se font franchement attendre et
c'est la grande évolution
la grande révolution pour moi en tout
cas au niveau de la téléphonie mobile et
c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment cool on
va se faire un petit historique pour
comprendre pourquoi ces smartphones à
écran pliable son tant attendu
on remonte en 2011 2011 samsung annonce
travailler sur un smartphone avec un
écran pliable depuis 2011 on en entend
beaucoup parler de temps en temps il
revient dans l'actu il re disparaissent
au final on n'a jamais rien jusqu'à
l'année dernière 2018
on sent effectivement que ça devient de
plus en plus pressant et on sent que les
smartphones pliable avec justement cet
écran pliable vont pas tarder à arriver
sur le marché d'ailleurs d'autres
fabricants disent travailler aussi sans
leur propre modèle lg howe est en tête
on s'attendait slowey présente sa copie
fin 2018 ce qui n'a pas été le cas
néanmoins samsung dans sa conférence des
développeurs a montré en catimini avec
très peu de lumière son smartphone à
écran pliable
on a vu très rapidement histoire de
mettre un peu l'eau à la bouche quelques
jours après auriol nous présente son
flex paille sa version de smartphones à
écran pliable
début 2019 je vais prendre en main ce
smartphone à écran pliable du royaume
pour qui il fondamentalement est un gros
coup de promo pour viol parce que le
produit pas vraiment extraordinaire est
pas bien abouti néanmoins la techno est
là et ça c'est plutôt intéressant
il n'y a pas très longtemps chez omis en
la personne de son co fondateur a
présenté son smartphone à écran pliable
a montrés dans une vidéo
le concept a l'air d'être vraiment
intéressant vraiment cool donc sans
l'attendre si elle d'ici quelques jours
quelques semaines et maintenant qu'est
ce qui va se passer alors déjà premier
rendez vous il ya l'impact de 20 février
de samsung pour présenter la nouvelle
gamme samsung galaxy s 10 et normalement
on pourrait avoir droit à cette vidéo
peut-être le produit sera présenté
directement sur scène je pense pas qu'on
ne prendra nous en main mais en tout cas
ce après franchement intéressant de voir
ce produit enfin abouti enfin dévoilée
par samsung donc ça c'est premier rendez
vous le 20 février
deuxième rendez vous ces quelques jours
après lors du mwc à fin du mois la
veille du mwc
la conférence de huawei où ils vont
présenter normalement leurs smartphones
à écran pliable 5g ça ça devrait être
énorme
le même jour il ya une conférence de
chez oh oui peut-être vont-ils présenter
officialisé montrer rapidement allez
savoir leur smartphone à écran pliable
en tout cas ce qu'on voit c'est que
l'actu autour des smartphones à écran
pliable et plus en plus pressante
c'est franchement hyper cool et de toute
façon ces trois rendez vous y serez donc
je vous invite à faire une seule chose
c'est à vous abonner et comme ça on
verra réellement ce qui se passe
directement sur le terrain le 20 février
puis ensuite pour ouais on chie romy et
puis lors du mwc parce qu'on va aller
voir toutes ces nouvelles techno et à
mon avis cette année et ce alors
franchement être assez énorme
parce qu'il faut bien voir ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre avec ses smartphones à
écran pliable c'est pas juste une techno
pour une technologie d'un smartphone qui
se plie ce n'est pas juste un effet
waouh ça va au delà de ça on est en
train d'arriver dans douai rebels tout
doucement tranquillement on y va on a
des smartphones en diva est comme ça ça
c'est un pixel 3 on a des smartphones un
peu standards qu'on met dans nos poches
ci et ça c'est plutôt bien mais on veut
toujours des écrans peut-être pas tout
le monde mais la plupart du monde en
tout cas vont sur des visages avec des
smartphones un guide plus grand écran
pour du multimédia pour du jeu vidéo
pour regarder des vidéos
mais par contre on veut qu'ils tiennent
très facilement dans la poche elle a
vite se retrouver une pas les sentir ça
serait même carrément mieux
l'idée effectivement d'abord un
smartphone avec un écran pliable
on voit qu'on va au final tout doucement
par la miniaturisation et des
smartphones qui pourrait peut-être
s'intégrer allez savoir
d'ici une dizaine d'années voire un peu
plus loin on sait pas trop à nos
vêtements à nous directement fin ça
montre en tout cas une vision de
l'avenir des techno qui voulut c'est
super intéressant et c'est justement en
ça que cette problématique des
smartphones à écran pliable est vraiment
intéressante parce qu'on sait que cette
année dure effectivement beaucoup
d'annoncés beaucoup de rendez vous il ya
beaucoup d'enjeux on attend
effectivement là la représentation des
galaxy s d'ici grossi une belle rotation
le fait par apple deuxième semestre 2010
huawei va sortir aussi des modèles très
important chahoumi également et d'autres
marques au pot one pleuvent
je vous en passe au nord et compagnie
donc ça c'est vraiment intéressant mais
ces modèles ne sont jamais que des
évolutions avec de nouvelles techno
embarquer plus de puissance plus de ta
forme ans la miniaturisation une
meilleure autonomie meilleures photos
mais on reste dans des évolutions là
avec les smartphones à écran pliable on
entraperçoit un futur qui en tout cas
assez intéressant d'un point de vue
technologique et 6 ans a vraiment que
j'ai en tout cas moi autres passionnés
de technologie j'ai toujours émerveillé
d'ailleurs je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
moi est ce que pour vous les smartphones
à écrans plats vont être la grande
nouveauté la grande d'évolution à grande
révolution pour la décennie à venir et
dites moi à votre avis vous ou est-ce
que vous pensez que ça va nous mener est
ce que vous pensez comme moi qu'on va
aller vraiment sur lui ou elle est belle
on peut l'imaginer intégrés à des bijoux
intégrés à des vêtements intégré à même
chose je dis pas ce que vous en pensez
et puis à la limite même pourquoi pas
avoir un smartphone complètement
dématérialisé mais là on se projette
vachement beaucoup plus loin de moi ce
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
et je vous invite à vous abonner parce
que tous ces événements on y sera comme
ça on en reparlera et dès le lendemain
la vidéo en ligne comme ça vous aurez
accès à toute l'actu de chaud ça c'est
cool d'ici là je vous embrasse soyez
salle prenez soin de vous ciao
[Musique]